سوداء
محمد عم يلعب بها
دغري خاف
هذه ليست مشاهد من فيلم رعب بل حادثه
حقيقيه ادت الى وفاه الاخ التوام لعلي ابن
السته اعوام
في حديقه حاره سور القديمه لفظ محمد
انفاسه الاخيره
فمجموعه من شابين وفتاتين قررت تمثيل
مشاهد رعب في فسحه مخصصه للاطفال لاطحاق
متابعيها على تيك توك فكانت النتيجه وفاه
طفل لم يتحمل قلبه مشاهده اشخاص باقنعه
وملابس سوداء شاهرين سيوفا حديديه
كانوا هاك ماشيين عم يركضوا وراه بصوص
وقف قلبه
طب هو شو السبيكر شو كان في
الاشياء المرعبه اغاني مرعبه
بطلب من الله يرد حق امه لها الصبي لانه
ابن نهار ومرته انهارت مرته مش عم تصحى مش
معقول قام يصير فيها هاي بسببه فلوسنا ابن
سبع سنين وامه
هيك روحوا لي شوربه مي اهمال اهمال
المسؤولين هاي اهمال مسؤولين مش بس هن
رغم ان البعض قد يصف ما حدث بالقضاء
والقدر الا ان الاهالي يصرون على محاسبه
الشبان الذين اتوا من قرى مجاوره فاوقفوا
بتهمه التسبب
بالقتلنا لا سمح الله نحن الهدف انه
يكونوا درس لاي شيء بدهم يعملوهن او غيرهن
يعني غيرهم يتعلم انه ياخذوا بالعين
الاعتبار السلام العامه لموقع التصوير
يكون في السلام العام يعني ما نستلجئ
بحياه الاولاد بحياه الكبار شيء مرعب اله
اماكن مساحه اللعب هذه توارثها الابناء عن
الاباء وهي امنه للاطفال خاصه وانها تقع
وسط منازلهم التي تبعد دقائق عن مكان وقوع
الحادثه التي هزت لبنان الكلام لن يخفف من
وقع الفاجعه لكن تسليط الضوء على القضيه
يبقى درسا شبان اتخذوا من وسائل التواصل
وسيله لكسب مشاهدات على حساب الاخرين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات